hallo mein name zom meine Damen und
Herren die Weihnachtszeit steht vor der
Tür dafür habe ich uns hier in Minecraft
eine kleine Welt erstellt mit ein
bisschen Schnee mit ein paar Fichten mit
Eisbergen hier vorne und mit
liting hilt euch mal den Schaden den das
macht ihr habt glaube ich schon in Titel
gelesen ich stelle euch heute die mega
TNT Mod vor es wird geisteskrank schaut
euch das noch mal
an
Alter mit mit einem Dynamit und ich
meine der Eisbär da vorne der wird nicht
mehr lang leben denn ich befinde mich im
Creative Mode und ihr seht schon es wird
nicht nur eine Menge Dynamit hinzugefügt
sondern auch mega tnts 2 3 4 und 5 also
extrem große Dinger schaut euch mal das
hier
an ich bin einfach ein riesen DnD Block
wenn Ihr sehen wollt wie ich das Ding in
die Luft springe was ist für ein Schaden
anrichtet und ob mein PC das überhaupt
schaffen wird dann lst jetzt schon mal
einen Daumen hoch unter diesem Video
hier da abonniert meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke um weitere Videos
nicht zu verpassen wir schauen uns jetzt
erstmal das normale Dynamit an beim
Dynamit gibt's nämlich verschiedene
Stufen Dynamit kann man generell nur
werfen und die erste Stufe ist das hier
ganz normales Einser Dynamit die nächste
Stufe ist das Fünfer Dynamit seht ihr
schon Tick größer ganz genau gesagt fünf
Mal so groß 20er Dynamit da sehen wir
ein ordentlichen
Unterschied warum Klang die Explosion
wie ein Furz so oder so kommt dann das
hundter Dynamite und wenn ich das hier
hinschmeiße seht ihr schon da passiert
ordentlich was das ist allerdings nicht
das einzige TNT bzw Dynamit in dieser
tntw was wir haben wir haben noch das
Tunnel Dynamite wir haben das cubic
Dynamite cool Dynamite bunkerbuster
water und dementsprechend auch noch Lava
wir haben Flat Dynamite sponge Dynamite
und das Bug Dynamite und noch ein paar
mehr ich zeig euch jetzt einfach mal das
Tunnel Dynamite sagt der Name eigentlich
schon es erschafft halt einfach ein
Tunnel können wir theoretisch auch mal
hier eine Seite reinschmeißen seht ihr
bei einem Berg was da vorne abgeht wir
kriegen einfach einen Gang gebaut der
perfekt zum farmen ist cubic dynamite
auch relativ selbst erklären ist einfach
ein Würfel der da erzeugt wird ich bin
ganz froh dass ich so ein guten PC der
das alles hinkriegt das cool Dynamite
ich weiß nicht was hieran cool sein soll
ich habe das auch alles natürlich schon
getestet heute den ganzen Tag lang damit
ich genau weiß wovon ich rede ist
einfach ein riesiges Dynamit so oder so
ist das bankkerbaster Dynamite von den
dynamitsorten mein zweit
lieblingsdynamit denn das kann man
einfach schmeißen und ihr seht schon man
bekommt einen großen tunnelkrater wie
auch immer man es nennen mag gegraben
bis zur badrock Höhe das heißt das ist
einfach irre das geht 200 50 Blöcke oder
so tief da können wir jetzt auch mal
anschließend das water Dynamite dran
schmeißen relativ selbsterklärend das
Gegenstück ist das Lava Dynamite brauch
ich glaube ich nicht viel zu sagen das
ganze kriegen wir dann auch mit dem
sponge Dynamite wieder weg das heißt D
der sponge der macht nicht so viel
Schaden wenn ich den z.B einfach hinwerf
passiert nzu gar nichts hier vorne aber
wenn du das irgendwie ins Wasser wirfst
zack verschwindet das Wasser in dem
kompletten Bereich das Flat Dynamite da
sehen wir den besten Vergleich wenn ich
einfach mal hier ein bisschen weiter
unten
gegenwererf seht ihr schon so ein etwas
höherer bere ich von 10 Blöcken wird
komplett in soem Radius von 30 Blöcken
zerstört dazu haben wir dann auch noch
den Bug Dynamite den verstehe ich
nicht das ist einfach ein Lagerfeuer ein
Schild und
Wasser okay so oder so kommen wir damit
und allerdings auch schon zum Mini
Dynamite ihr seht schon das Ding ist
echt Mini allerdings werden auch ein
paar kreative Sachen hinzugefügt z.B das
Mini Haus Dynamite da wird ein kleines
Haus erschaffen und es gibt auch das
Haus Dynamite da wird ein relativ großes
Haus erschaffen für ein Start und das
ist sogar schon ganz gut ausgestattet im
großen Haus z.B wo ist in der Eingang
hier vorne haben wir direkt schon zwei
Betten drin wir haben hier vorne alles
was wir erstmal so zum Craften benötigen
und wir haben auch ein Weg nach oben
nach draußen im Kleinhaus ist es
natürlich ein bisschen sperlicher ihr
seht schon kannst reingehen natürlich
klar ist auch ein Bett und eine Kiste da
sprechen dann die Items eher für sich
das ist mir nicht ganz viel aufeinander
platzieren ach
lol da kann ich wirklich ein Hochhaus
bauen so oder so haben wir dann auch
noch das animal Dynamite und das wird
jetzt richtig
laut machen wir weiter mit dem mining
Dynamite das knst du hier reinschmeißen
und dann siehst du
schon das meint für dich selber und
generiert auch so ein paar Spitzhacken
es gibt auch noch das palzdynamite das
schmei jetzt mal da rein da denkst auch
erstmal passiert gar nichts aber es
passiert halt die ganze Zeit was und das
macht quasi immer weiter und mein für
dich den kompletten Bereich bis es dann
jetzt gleich
aufhört ihr seht schon es hat auf jeden
Fall ordentlich Schaden angerichtet dass
i sind natürlich so Grafikfehler kennt
ihr wahrscheinlich von Minecraft was ist
den das für eine Riesenhöhle hier
unten was geht denn hier ab das wäre
perfekt für mein Cluster
Dynamite alter Schwede ich glaube das
wegt hier unten in eh schon komplett
zerstörten Höhle nicht so krass wie es
an top hier vorne an der Oberwelt wirkt
aber wir erstellen quasi einfach
tausende dnts die dann
explodieren es ist so
irre es ist so
krass es ist so satisfying aber gut wir
müssen weitermachen das Nether Dynamite
sagt der Name schon erstellt einfach
eine netherwelt und das end Dynamite
erstellt das Ende in der Oberwelt so
oder so sind das erstmal die Basic
dynamites die hinzugefügt werden wir
haben in der Dynamite Kategorie das habe
ich mich vorhin schon gefragt warum das
hier mit drin ist die Throwable tnts
auch noch denn TNT kann man natürlich
nicht nur wie das in Minecraft so üblich
ist hinsetzen und dann mit einer
Redstone Fackel oder einem Feuerzeug
anzünden ich kann euch das mal hier
vorne ganz kurz zeigen TNT hin Redstone
Fackel perfekt ich Idiot ich Idiot ich
hab's das ist ein ganz normales TNT und
es wirkt total affig wenn man das
einfach so sieht das throw TNT ist aber
ganz cool denn ich kann jetzt einfach
sagen ich will da hinten TNT hinwerfen
und dann platziert es sich genau dahin
wo ich es hingeworfen habe ich habe es
jetzt zwar direkt neben die Lava
geschmissen aber es entzündet sich auch
von selbst wenn ich einfach hier auf dem
Schnee setze oder hier oder da oder da
also da wo ich hingucke schmeiße ich ein
TNT hin und dann explodiert do einfach
so von selbst das Ganze gibt auch noch
mal fünf das ist einfach der fünffache
Schaden sieht man keinen großen
Unterschied bei 20fach allerdings schon
das gibt's auf jeden Fall auch noch so
oder so ist das dann erstmal das
komplette mega tnts Mods dyamite wir
haben allerdings noch die mega tnts Tier
2 Tier 3 Tier 4 und Tier 5 das sind
basically die gleichen nur dass Tier 5
natürlich das krasseste ist das habe ich
schon getestet dabei ist mein PC
abgeschmiert da steht do don't try this
if you don't want to weiter kann man
nicht lesen aber want to kill your
computer wahrscheinlich so oder so würde
ich sagen schauen wir uns noch mal hier
von das kolossale TNT an denn das ist
wirklich das krasseste was ich hier
gesehen habe das ist ein riesiges TNT
Set mal ganz kurz die Zeit hier auf
morgen und wir brauchen dafür auch einen
Ort der eigentlich relattiv egal ist
dieses Ding sprengt alles in die Luft
was es irgendwie gibt wir nehmen uns mal
eine Redstone Fackel ich setzt es mal
hier
neben und jetzt seht ihr schon der Hase
der tut mir jetzt schon leid die
Explosion muss nämlich erstmal gerändert
werden und ich sag euch das dauert einen
kleinen Moment wir sind jetzt gerade
erst bei
20% und wenn in Minecraft ein Spiel was
eh schon immer so ein bisschen am
ruckeln ist erstmal noch was gerändert
werden muss in Game dann hat es so ein
bisschen was zu heißen wir sind jetzt
noch nicht mal bei der Hälfte und das
ist Tier 4 es gibt noch Tier 5 eine
Stunde
später das da rechts war mal der
Hase und wenn wir jetzt mal schauen
weit und breit
nichts wir befanden uns auf einer Höhe
von locker 150 oder so in Minecraft
jetzt sind wir auf Höhe - 60 hier vorne
kommt D mal so langsam so die die Wand
damit ihr auch mal seht in welcher Tiefe
das hier wirklich stattgefunden hat ne
da ist ganz unten da sind wir noch immer
nicht ganz oben also es lädt ja weiter
ich kann mal hinfliegen also es geht
hier wir
ist so geistig in welcher Entfernung das
hier irgendwie abgeht und das ist halt
der Krater der erschaffen wird mit einem
kolossalen TNT auch lustig wie das hier
rumfliegt kolossalen TNT Tier 4 wenn ihr
die ganzen Mod mal testen wollt mit Tier
5 und schauen wollt auf EU PC das klappt
ich würd es euch nicht empfehlen dann
habe ich euch auf jeden Fall trotzdem
unten in der Beschreibung verlinkt
checkt es auf jeden Fall mal ab es sind
noch ein paar mehr Sachen hinzugefügt
worden es gibt noch nukleare tnts
giftige tnts nur katzentnts Creeper tnts
also einiges ist noch am Start wofür das
heutige Video gar nicht reicht wenn ich
dazu noch ein zweiten Teil machen soll
schreibt mal unten in die Kommentare
lasst ein Daumen hoch unter dem Video
hier da wenn es euch gefallen hat
abonniert meinen Kanal und klickt auf
die Glocke weitere Videos nicht zu
verpassen ich schaue jetzt erstmal dass
ich mein Minecraft wieder ans Laufen
Krieg